[Music]
metallica's that family i never had or
always wanted that i found in a band
artist of the year goes to metallica
we all know each other and we continue
after 40 years to learn more about each
other
[Applause]
we're going to talk about how we write
songs how to get the best out of
everyone without dominating we're gonna
break down some of the most classic
metallica songs
and we're gonna give you a badass
performance
as far as lyrics go i will have spaces
where i need a vocal and then i'll
search through some of my one-liners
and go how rhythmically that fits
so i'll plug that in and start building
around that
when you're in a band communication is
key if you have a problem talk about it
with a level head a mantra for us is
whatever's best for the project
that helps to well the ego
in the early days there was so much just
there's been times when it's been
fractured and it looks like we were on
the verge of breaking up
30 years ago we come off stage and we go
you [ __ ] that up and you [ __ ] that up
nowadays we go ha ha ha that was really
funny that was a crazy variation at the
end of the day it's a [ __ ] robin roll
song
when you're in a band the commitment is
to music but after a while you realize
it's a real commitment to each other
that's what being a band is all about
coming together to create great things
if there's anything in what we're about
to share that in any way inspires you
influences you makes you want to jump
into any creative endeavor particularly
music then we've done our job
i'm james hetfield i'm robert trujillo
i'm kirk hammett i'm lars ort we are
metallica and this is masterclass
[Music]
now the world is gone
[Music]